[Musik]
lexi tech trees ton
[Applaus]
ein jahr voller unruhen und der längsten
us bei der geschichte und dann zu
schauen dass du bald heute haben sich
variante die beiden ja weitgehend im
wahlkampf gelegen hatte
das ist eine historische wahl ist eine
bieten sie noch nie hatte
[Musik]
die sie sich beziehen
mitunter muss
straflager stadt meinungsfreiheit
in diesen anspruch von alexander meier
in der reihe 13 cad t
[Musik]
ein jahr der schweiz
ich habe bereits vor einer woche gesagt
dass es zusätzliche massnahmen braucht
der kann
die unterdrückung
[Musik]
die makler schneller bewegung nächsten
ist ein sieg ist es ein atrium
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der bruch einer monarchie
ein jahr der zerstörung
[Musik]
die geburtsstunde des weltraumtourismus
in dieser kapsel sitzen wir zu viert und
dann fliegt die rakete ins all
[Musik]
jetzt sieht man hinter mir den start der
völkern rakete die rakete bewegt sich
gegen den himmel man hört jetzt auch das
donnergrollen der triebwerke
immer wieder spritzen und lockdown
maßnahmen
[Musik]
ein dreikampf um das kanzleramt
sieht gerade neben ihr armin laschet ist
jetzt gerade hallo werden uns heute aus
der regierungsmaschine jetzt soll auf
dem rückweg nach
[Musik]
ein wahlkampf wieder singen sie nicht
bestimmen jetzt vielleicht
schafft es schon ganz alleine da
die dramatische flucht nach 20 jahren
einsatz am hindukusch
man kann sich kaum bewegen alles ist
vorbei
die ja viele viele kinder sind irritiert
müssen immer mehr leute hier noch einen
korb weil nicht genügend platz für sie
selbst zusammen gerückt
ein jahr fließender lavaströme
und immer wieder
pandemie
das war immer klar für diesen herbst und
winter braucht es weiterhin
schutzmaßnahmen
[Musik]
wie besiegt olaf scholz coroner schönen
guten abend herr scholz
einem jahr der flucht
[Musik]
dieser schleuse werden dann viele auch
durch nachtsichtgeräte von der
polnischen grenzschutz polizei dann
aufgegriffen
[Musik]
ein jahr des abschieds und ein jahr
[Applaus]
wir wissen jetzt jedenfalls bei uns im
studio bild kolumnist alexander von
schönburg mit ihm wollten einst ihr
verabschieden so was von dem studio alex
wir wollen alles finden was war das
eigentlich für ein ja was hat uns da
besonders bewegt berührt was hat uns
aufgeregt ja ich habe eine lange liste
vorbereitet die kann ich jetzt nicht
mehr kann ich jetzt sich riesigen
monolog halten ist mir nach einer halben
stunde hier aber überrascht als ich das
als ich da sagen aber die bilder des
vergangenen jahres revue passieren
lassen war zunächst überrascht dieser
schreckliche sturm auf das kapitol zum
beispiel war dieses jahr es kommt eben
nach meinem sohn dieser ewig lange her
anderes sein das waren 6 januar das war
das war das war genau vor einem jahr und
da muss man wirklich sagen denn man hat
das ja ziemlich schlecht angefangen denn
es ist ja nicht nur für uns journalisten
sondern
sondern für alle menschen wird
geschichte findet in bildern statt und
im nachhinein könnte man sagen das war
gar nicht so schlimm ist 140 polizisten
verletzt worden ist unglaublich viel
tote gewesen man kann das kleinreden da
was man nie klein reden kann ist die
verheerende wirkung diese bilder hatten
plötzlich
die vereinigten staaten von amerika die
für uns alle ja der war schon durch die
architektur die dort auf geboten wird
wie das alte athen sozusagen aufleben
lässt die sich diese stolzen gebäude
gebe dort sind die ja wenn wirkliche art
geschändet wurden muss man sagen das
waren bilder die wir für uns die so
aufgewachsen sind amerika ist das
vorbild an eine parlamentarische
demokratie und auch so eine hoffnung ort
für viele leute die baby aus der aus
anderen weniger demokratischen ländern
dorthin schauen und diese dieses kapital
vor sich haben die an diesem tag ist
wirklich was kaputt gegangen und ich
habe den ich habe schon die zeitschrift
mitgebracht von nächster woche also vom
neuen jahr die economist und economist
interessanten neuen titel und zeigt sie
die elefant ist ja das symbol für die
republikanische partei und sie zeigt wie
die republikanische partei walking away
steht hier also raus geht aus dem aus
dem demokratischen prozessen dieses
dieser hat dieses gebäude was das
angedeutet ist eben die unsere
institutionen und ich habe gerade
gelesen dass 40 prozent der
amerikaner auf der konservativen seite
und 40 auf der linken seite der anderen
seite komplett misstrauen und sagen das
sind dass das in diesen alle des teufels
also wir haben dass wir wirklich gesehen
haben ist eine spaltung die dort
und auch ein mist ja ein jahr ein grill
und ein misstrauen auf die institution
und da sehen wir heute in deutschland
das gleiche also wenn ich jetzt nämlich
jetzt ein jahr revue passieren lassen
und die heute und die heute gebet oder
bild -zeitung anschauen oder oder war es
gestern wo wir gezeigt haben mit unseren
polizisten umgegangen wird wie sehen
überall was in diesem jahr geschehen ist
ein zerfall des vertrauens in den staat
ist ein zerfall des zusammenhalts da und
was eben diese bilder von bärbel bilder
vom kapitol leben gezeigt haben die
institutionen genießen nicht mehr den
respekt den sie den sie noch hatten
deswegen lass uns ganz kurz auch auf die
schöne dinge des jahres noch
nicht berührt haben auf jeden fall also
schöne dinge müsste ich jetzt sehr
überspringen was das schönste für mich
war dass daniel craig abgelöst worden
wurde als als gentleman und ich finde es
super schauspieler aber er war für mich
von anfang an mich die nicht die james
bond figur wenn du mich noch fragen wenn
du mich noch fragen möchte meine
highlights mein highlight also die ich
ja war sicher
also das ist jetzt persönlich ich freue
mich über den neuen bayern trainer ist
der trainer ich finde dass man ist ein
toller ist eine tolle figur auch als
trainertyp ich habe mir die doku neulich
über bayern angeschaut dann sagte er er
sagte diese später seine plötzlich so
gut da hieß es ja weil ich den einfach
mag und er hat seine persönliche
ansprache gibt den leuten so wind in den
segeln ich bin da können wir auch als
führungskräfte vieler von lernen als
journalistin wir holten die beste
leistung aus den leuten raus die
stimmung muss gut sein könnte ein moment
auf der amazon kommt kann man so als
verbissen immer in erinnerung hatten
plötzlich sagt er kann ja dann so viel
druck ist da muss auch immer wieder
dazwischen spaß sein sonst geben wir dem
druck kaputt und da fühle ich mich ein
bisschen lieber über bild was ich noch
was mich noch gefreut hat für mich in
musk mann des jahres beim time magazine
also da hat es auf twitter sehr die
geheime darüber gegeben ich muss sagen
nämlich beeindruckt dieser typ unendlich
er ist der henry ford also der unseres
zeitalters an himmelfahrt war der massen
geht es um das auto als massenprodukt im
grunde eher entdeckt hat und vermarktet
hat und für mich ist in maßen nicht nur
als unternehmer sondern auch als mensch
einfach
beeindrucken ich erinnere mich hat sich
je nach berlin kam und hier den axel
springer preis bekommen hat dieses video
dieses interview von mathias döpfner mit
mittelmaß kann man immer noch auf
youtube anschauen es lohnt sich wirklich
verlassen gehen sie nicht aus dem jahr
und dieses video angeschaut zu haben es
ist man bis man ist wirklich gebannt von
bilder von auch der authentizität dieses
mannes und von der intelligenz von
seinen visionären von serien visionären
ausblicken was ich am meisten
beeindruckt hat er ist ja sehr sehr
reich der reichste mann der welt und
dann sagte döpfner ihm ja wo schlafen
sie heute nacht merziger der inhalte
halbe adlon gemietet haben ein er fuhr
tatsächlich nachts raus
in seine fabrik und hat seine
mitarbeiter dort gezwungen ihm dort ein
feldbett aufzustellen und übernommen hat
dort übernachteten der grund dafür war
nicht so wie man das sagen wir glauben
würde ja ja wir uns irgendwas sagt nein
er wollte im gefühl haben für diese
fabrik und so waren sozusagen die
gründerzeit unternehmer vor 200 jahren
also auch der alte krupp hat auf dem
firmengelände geschlafen und wollte
aufwachen und den geruch der hochöfen
oder wollte einfach wissen er wird das
gefühl sagt und interessanterweise ich
habe gestern in der nz ein riesen
porträt über ihn gelesen was sie eben
geschrieben wurde anlässlich der der
tatsache dass er mehr ist beim thema
gesehen das macht ja auch immer öfter
dass der in seine fabriken geht und dort
mit am band mitarbeitet und zwar nicht
symbolisch und so ist eine kamera heben
sondern macht das paar stunden lang bis
spät in die nacht habe ich dort gelesen
dass er regelmäßig doch dorthin geht
einfach um das gefühl der der dein mann
des jahres sozusagen in der maske eine
figur die ich besonders berührt
besonders fasziniert in diesem jahr was
würde eigenen mosk wohl sagen der mann
der raketen mittlerweile in den weltraum
schickt über unser böllerverbot hier in
deutschland das wir nicht mehr diese
dinge hier in den himmel ist es für dich
eine traurige geschichte zu silvester
alex oder ich habe mich zu machen sie
dieser so geliebt ich mache mir so
unbeliebt ich freue mich ehrlich gesagt
für die vielen tiere in der stadt den
nicht leiden ich viel ich fühle mich ich
freue mich für die tiere den winter
schlafen nicht unterbrochen wird ich
freue mich für die ganzen igel und ich
freue mich für die haustiere jetzt liegt
die bin ich so leiden ich dass ich weiß
ist unpopulär ich habe viele freunde die
ganz anderer meinung sind ich bin ich
finde feuerwerke gehören in die hand von
profis das soll man sich dann anschauen
und ich mag aber das hat dann mit sogar
mit zusammen hat sich in berlin ein
serbe fahnen oder belebten straße wohne
ich mag die ballerei persönlich in
berlin nicht ich traue mich da nicht auf
die straße ich bin auch eher ein muffel
möchte ich auch immer ins bett gehen